this episode was made in collaboration
with our changing climate
be sure to check out their video after
this
[Music]
the world faces a lot of challenges from
poverty to war
to famine to disease our species has a
lot of problems that need solving
but there's one problem that is not only
incredibly threatening on its own
but also makes all the other problems
much worse climate change
the result of natural atmospheric
changes and intense human activity and
pollution
poses an existential threat to not only
humans but
countless other species around the world
if we're going to mitigate some of the
worst effects of climate fallout
we need to start making real changes
immediately unfortunately
that doesn't look like it's going to
happen in this episode
we're going to talk about the basics of
climate change and why capitalism is not
equipped to handle the crisis
before we get into the analysis i think
we should start with some simple facts
about climate change
i'll start at square zero climate change
is happening
it is not debatable regardless of
whether or not you think humans are
causing or worsening the problem
you cannot claim that we are not
witnessing serious changes to the
planet's climate
the evidence is sound and overwhelming
the only detractors are people who are
either a
not experts in the field or b paid by
the oil and gas industry to spread
disinformation
usually both even if you're not
convinced by the consensus of the entire
scientific community
the effects of climate change are
something you can see for yourself
i recently visited maduro in the
marshall islands as part of a
documentary crew
we saw homes literally being consumed by
the sea
islands and coastal regions are going
underwater and this is only one of the
side effects of climate change
okay i hope we're on the same page here
climate change is happening
and the fallout is already doing serious
damage to communities around the world
there's a certain type of person who
always appears in the comments of this
type of video to say things like
humans have nothing to do with climate
change this is just a normal part of
earth's climate cycles
i'm sure there will be some of these
people on this video too
to address those people you're wrong and
even if you were completely correct
the consequences of the changing climate
are so severe that we must take
significant steps to mitigate the loss
of life and spiraling global crises
think of it like this if you're out for
a walk and someone is driving straight
at you and you're clearly going to be
run over
what would you do you'd do everything in
your power to avoid being run over right
does it really matter whether the driver
is purposely trying to kill you or if
their brakes are out
no because the end result is undesirable
either way
the things that led up to you having to
avoid getting hit by a car shouldn't
factor into your consideration of how to
respond
the same is true of climate fallout so
with that out of the way
let's look at a few basic facts about
climate change and its disastrous
effects
we'll start with the bad news even if we
completely stopped emitting greenhouse
gases today
we've already set in motion a scenario
which will inevitably release
more warming agents that have been
trapped in ice for thousands or millions
of years
this will cause serious problems the
world over already hot areas will face
record heat waves and droughts
which will adversely affect food
production continued warming and
acidification of the world's oceans will
destroy fragile ecosystems like coral
reefs and threaten fish populations
which billions of people rely on for
food
islands and coastal regions are at risk
of flooding or complete submersion
as i documented in the marshall islands
as warm seasons last
longer disease-carrying insects will
become more prevalent and occupy larger
areas
infecting countless people with
life-threatening illnesses
farming regions will be at tremendous
risk of crop failure as local weather
behaves erratically or changes
completely
in the developing world crop failure and
drought will combine to create
massive water and food shortages
resulting in unspeakable death tolls and
the worsening of the world's ongoing
poverty and migrant crises
sooner or later oil will cease to be the
most valuable resource to imperialist
nations
it will be replaced by water when the
most basic necessity of life becomes a
target for military action and
occupation
we will begin to see suffering unlike
the human race has ever seen
but this video isn't about all the
specific details of climate fallout
i've covered that topic in previous
videos if you're interested
what we really need to talk about is how
the current dominant economic system
presents an
insurmountable obstacle to mitigating
climate disaster
so let's take a look at a few of the
actions as determined by the ipcc
which must be taken immediately or at
least in the very near future
according to the ipcc's climate and land
report
we need to implement comprehensive early
warning systems for extreme weather
as well as other observational programs
to monitor land use and degradation
biodiversity and the spread of
disease-bearing insects
we need to fund programs that will
encourage sustainable land management
which will prevent desertification and
famine we need to invest in land
restoration
bringing damaged or endangered soil and
biomes back from the brink
we must drastically reduce greenhouse
gas emissions across all sectors
including oil and gas agriculture
transportation and leisure
and we need to do all of these things in
just a few years to prevent global
catastrophe
now let's consider the nature of the
roadblock that is capitalism
to offer a simple definition capitalism
is an economic system in which the means
of production are controlled by private
owners and corporations
the primary driver of capitalism is the
profit motive
the desire for ever-increasing profits
and the accumulation of capital
it should be obvious that the very
premise of capitalism is antithetical to
any kind of long-term planning
if a system demands greater profits
every year if it demands infinite growth
it will inevitably run into the very
real problem of existing on a planet
with finite resources
if we look at the decisions made by
large multinational corporations
say exxon for example it's clear that
those decisions are made
based solely on the amount of short-term
profit they will produce
back in the 70s when exxon was at the
forefront of climate research
their scientists determined just how
detrimental fossil fuels are to the
planet
instead of making this information
public and working with policymakers to
find a solution
they marked those documents confidential
and launched a decades-long propaganda
campaign to sow doubt on the effects of
greenhouse gas emissions
by doing this they secured their
short-term profits at the expense of the
long-term survival
of millions of human beings the same is
true of giant companies like amazon
jeff bezos amazon's ceo and the richest
person on the planet
could easily afford to make amazon
employees the best paid workers in the
world
thereby securing a happy and loyal labor
force and positive public perception of
the company
instead amazon is among the worst places
to work in the country
we routinely hear horror stories about
how employees have to pee in bottles
because they'll be fired if they take a
bathroom break
or how they've had to ignore a co-worker
who had died on the floor
reducing overhead by exploiting workers
yields greater short-term profits
but it turns the public against the
company causes massive turnover
and damages their own long-term survival
by ensuring its workers have neither the
time nor the disposable income to buy
their products
this kind of behavior is common among
capitalist companies
including many smaller ones today it's
exceptionally rare to find a job that
pays a reasonable salary or offers
benefits of any kind
the name of the game is reducing costs
to maximize profits
that is the only goal of capitalism so
if we can't count on capitalism to even
take care of the workers that keep the
system running
how can we expect it to make provisions
for people on the other side of the
world
or who haven't even been born yet the
scientific community
knows that nothing will get done unless
there's a profit to be made so
their reports often contain return on
investment timelines and estimates
but if you look at their numbers there's
no way an oil executive or cruise line
ceo would go for it
sustainable land management programs
that might be profitable in 10 years
the crews and oil industries are
incredibly profitable now
why would they take a reduction in
profits when those profits are their
sole motivating factor
and if the big lobbies won't go for it
neither will the politicians who rely on
their donations
the most damaging industries also just
so happen to have the largest political
lobbies they make tremendous profits
from exploiting workers at home and
abroad
not to mention the limited resources of
the earth itself and they're willing to
shell out tens of millions of dollars to
fund politicians and propaganda
campaigns so they can keep doing it
even if you're inclined to be optimistic
and hope that these people will have a
change of heart
just look at the historical record when
multinational companies set up shop in
central america
they made enormous profits they could
have paid their local workers a good
wage
or at least a living wage instead they
were little more than slaves
the workers were brutalized by corporate
paramilitary groups
they had their families threatened if
they weren't productive enough
some parents even received the severed
hands of their children if they didn't
meet their required quota
if these people were willing to maim or
even kill their workers
why would we assume they would be
willing to make massive concessions to
help mitigate climate fallout
to take a more recent example i live in
texas the temperature is the lowest
they've seen in decades
more than 620 000 waking up without
power in texas this morning
during the recent winter storm that
knocked out the state's power grid
it became clear that deregulation and
rampant cost cutting were a major part
of the problem
texas has its own electrical grid
separate from the country's two primary
grids
the goal was to completely deregulate
the texas energy market to free it from
the evils of bureaucracy
the end result as we should expect was
rampant corruption
price gouging and cost cutting officials
decided not to take precautionary
measures like winter proofing our
electrical infrastructure
because of this millions of texans lost
power had no access to clean drinking
water
and some even froze to death in their
own homes
this example is perhaps even more
damning than the previous one
because it deals specifically with
infrastructure the majority of climate
mitigation measures will be investments
in infrastructure
if these critical projects are avoided
simply as a way to cut costs
people will die and unfortunately i
think this negligent behavior is what we
need to expect from private corporations
and corporate owned politicians
the only goal of capitalism the only
thing that matters
is profit profits must increase every
year
the entire history of capitalism is the
history of the exploitation of working
people
especially by multinational corporations
and the us military operating in the
global south
climate change is shaping up to be the
single most expensive challenge humanity
has ever faced
the world is relying on the wealthiest
nations those that disproportionately
contribute to emissions and consumption
to lead the way in fighting climate
change as we've seen in the last decade
there hasn't been a single
administration willing to take steps
bold enough to meet the challenge
all we've seen is politicians paying lip
service to establish science while
peddling woefully insufficient policies
that are rarely acted upon
if we want to ensure a livable future
for the human race
we must move past capitalism capitalism
is incapable of solving the problems it
creates
it is entirely beholden to the profit
motive and no amount of flowery language
greenwashing or reform will ever change
that
if you'd like to learn more about the
specifics of capitalism and its
relationship to the climate crisis
i highly recommend you check out our
changing climates companion video
it's a great crash course on the history
of capitalist exploitation of the people
and the planet if you enjoyed this video
consider dropping a like
if you hated it a thumbs down you can
check out my previous videos by clicking
the links on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week
you